nous sommes avec julien vincent délégué
syndical central cfdt amazon on soir
julien vincent merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous sur rt france un commentaire
sur la cour d'appel de versailles
aujourd'hui bah on est satisfait du
jugement le tribunal reconnaît enfin là
les carences d'amazon en matière de
santé sécurité donc donc cette issue du
jugement alors amazon a contrario dit
nous mettons en place toutes les mesures
de distanciation nécessaire est ce
réellement le cas
on parle d' amazon france bien sûr
amazon c'est plutôt un gros agglomérat
de petites mesurettes du sco à tubes
lexsi l'az yahia aucune prise en compte
du risque global et c'est ce qui est
reproché par le par les juges
aujourd'hui
donc concrètement qu'est ce qui pose
encore problème ce sont les coller qu'il
ne faudrait pas touché qu est ce qu est
ce qui pose réellement problème ou est
ce que c'est la distance entre les
personnes qui travaillent dans les
usines amazon la distance aller à peu
près respectées c'est surtout la
manipulation des articles puisque avant
entre l'entrée et la sortie de du poli
il ya cinq-six suis personnes qui vont
toucher l'article
donc le virus se transmet via l'e coli
bien les articles et ce problème là ne
veux pas être traité par amazon donc
c'est sur ce point là qu'on va surtout
devoir avancer
alors comment avancer puisque amazon
serait autorisée à livrer des produits
de première nécessité mais là aussi il
ya des colliers à manipuler il ya des
colliers manipuler mais on a tout un tas
de possibilités d'organisation
différentes pour pouvoir faire en sorte
qu'un seul salarié manipule un article
du début à la fin de la chaîne par
exemple mais amazon ne veut pas remettre
en cause ses process y compris en cas de
co vide donc la situation est un peu
bloquée tant qu'il ne t'en qu'il revient
d'un poids vers nous pourrons négocier
tous ces aspects là de l'organisation du
travail
ça va rester bloqué comment ça va se
passer effectivement il doit revoir sa
copie et ça va se passer en concertation
avec avec les délégués syndicaux comment
ça va se passer
ben on aurait pu l'aspect l'espérer
après le premier jugement lundi la
décision d'amazon ça plutôt été de ne
pas le faire en fait fermer le site et
nous faire nous balader sur et sur les
sites pour prendre des mesures est
encore donc on espère qu'ils vont
changer un peu d'attitude pour qu'on
puisse réellement avancer il qu'on
puisse trouver les entrepôts est-ce que
vous
et n'y est pas qu amazon prennent des
mesures plus drastiques il a fermé
évidemment ces entrepôts depuis l'a
promis le premier jugement est-ce que
amazon ne va pas tout simplement se
retirer de france
non c'est un marché de plusieurs
milliards d'euros donc sauf un scoop une
main il ya vraiment plus neutre et le
partir de france
qu'en est il du 11 mai ce qu amazon sera
soumis toujours aux mêmes règles selon
vous à partir du 11 mai que
demandez-vous précisément pour la sortie
du confinement
pour l'heure le 11 mai n'est pas une
date qui figure dans le logement le
jugement parle d'un mois pour ce qui est
de la sortie du confinement on de ce
qu'on voit dans les médias pour
l'instant il ya inquiet près nulle part
donc on n'est pas sûr du tout le 11 mai
soit une date à retenir pour l'instant
et que dites vous à ceux qui disent
amazon est condamné pour livrer des
produits qui ne serait pas de première
nécessité alors que d'autres sites en on
le sait avant de tout autre objet aux
français aujourd'hui
pourquoi amazon ferait exception mais la
différence avec d'autres sites c'est que
ces sites là ont joué la carte du
dialogue social et ont négocié dès le
début de la crise des mesures permettant
la santé sécurité alors qu amazon a
préféré foncé profiter des premières
semaines de confinement et une fois que
ça s'est emballé il avait toujours un
train de retard ils l'ont encore donc
maintenant il faut payer alors prochaine
étape vous l'espérez un dialogue
évidemment sur les mesures à prendre que
demandez vous vous concrètement pour
travailler correctement
après ça va être des termes très
technique mais on demande du pick and
back donc le cd des process de
manipulation d'art typique à une seule
personne
des réductions d'effectifs pour
permettre la distanciation des flux
séparer des parents des entrées des
sorties séparés avec 15 10 10 15 minutes
d'écart il ya tout un tas de mesures
qu'on peut prendre sans affecter trop
l'activité mais ça nécessite des
changements qu amazon ne veut pas
entendre pour l'instant merci beaucoup
julien vincent on va suivre évidemment à
cette affaire merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rt france